what do you think about the protest on
campus against Israel every protest I've
been
to has had the exact same tenor has had
the exact same messaging but you always
have that idiot or two that shows up
with a
sign and no one knows who that idiot is
ironically never comes with anybody else
always shows up somehow in the middle of
the protest and puts up a sign that says
something completely contrary to the
messaging of the protest and all the
cameras shift towards that guy I see it
every single time but the
overwhelming tenor of all of these
protests has been consistent it's been
calling for Freedom it's been calling
for Liberation it's been calling for an
end to the genocide a ceasefire an end
to the occupation an end to the
apartheid I will tell you what many
people are not seeing Columbia
University two IDF soldiers former IDF
soldiers spraying Palestinian protesters
with skunk water which is what the IDF
uses on Palestinian protesters and
sometimes on worshippers on their way to
Mid
AA uh which has multiple uh Health
repercussions and so I was reading about
how one of the students that was sprayed
on campus at Colombia Palestinian
student you know has showered at this
point of us doing this podcast 11 times
cannot get the smell out of her has
suffered all sorts of health issues as a
result of being sprayed again people are
not seeing the other side here people
are not seeing what we've had to deal
with at these protests right the open
bigotry and I want you to think about
this by the way people go and serve in
the IDF and then come back to the United
States or the United
Kingdom and they're not stigmatized for
participating in apartheid policies or
participating in a genocide how am I
supposed to feel as a Palestinian
knowing that this guy right next to me
participated in murdering my relatives
in Gaza right and has open reain to say
what he wants to say or do what he wants
to do and so we haven't seen the other
side of that as well but i' I'd
recommend to anyone that's uh talking
about you know prop Palestine protests
to actually go see one if you go to the
protests you listen to what's being said
you don't just capture I mean you got
400,000 people uh don't just go try to
find you're going to find four stupid
people at 400 at a protest of 400,000
people right because the protest scene
is always messy but I think that this is
um a sign of the
outrage and the anger and the
frustration that many students have
about being silenced again in the media
in academic settings um professors are
Los losing their jobs students are
having their faces put on trucks being
doxed uh the Shady watch lists that get
put out I'm on a few of them as well and
I just don't care anymore right but you
got these Shady watch lists people are
losing their uh their jobs at law
firms uh they're losing all of their
future opportunities young Palestinian
students because of something that they
they tweeted that's being taken out of
context 10 years ago right when they
were 17 years old it's ridiculous and so
I think that um you know we have to we
have to listen to the overwhelming
majority of voices of people that are
demonstrating for justice not
demonstrating against anyone but
demonstrating for people uh again
there's a large pronounced Jewish
Presence at every single Pro Palestine
March in fact if you look at uh the
organizations the groups that have taken
over uh Capitol Hill and and you know
train stations it's been if not now not
not an our name never again means for
anyone right it's been Jewish groups
many Jewish anti-occupation groups that
have been at the Forefront and I think
that that's where we have to pay
attention to the beauty of how diverse
this movement for free Palestine has
actually been so the average sentiment
is
anti-occupation not
anti-semitic it's incredibly lazy
incredibly lazy to say that anti-zionism
or that anti-occupation is anti-Semitic
first and foremost the Palestinians are
a Semitic people that's number one
number two
um look I'm proud of my community my
community has stood against
anti-Semitism in this country the Muslim
Community has been at the Forefront of
condemning anti-Semitism we have stood
in front of synagogues we have stood
with the Jewish Community when the
Jewish Community is attacked this is
about occupation this is a story of a
colonial entity that has driven us out
of our homes and has done so in such a
way that has forced us to try to be the
voice of a people that are being
exterminated overseas right now this is
not an anti-semitic movement this is a
pro- Freedom Movement do you think the
protests ever go to too
far the protest scene is a messy scene
and so again you're going to have
sometimes that oddd speaker or people
get carried away in their emotions and
yes sometimes people chant things or do
things that are contrary to the protests
it's pretty unfair when you judge the
entire protest Movement by some of these
incidents that have happened at protests
and you don't pay attention to what
they're protesting about in the first
place which is a genocide right now
everything is secondary to ending a
genocide that is ongoing in the in the
course of this
discussion it's not an exaggeration to
say that at least 30 40 people would
have been killed just over the last few
hours because we're averaging 135 to 150
a day
so everything else is secondary to that
this is where we all need to be right
now as people of conscience how do we
stop this because every single day is
deeply
costly
that